But are Americanisms trashing British English?
According to Lane, many of these American words are actually British in origin.
We took Lane out to pound the sidewalks of London...
...to see if Londoners knew the origins of their words.
What do you call this that we're walking on right now?
Pavement.
Okay, now I said the word "sidewalk," what would that make you think of?
Sidewalk is an obvious Americanism except that it originated in Britain.
It was being used already in the early 1800s to describe the footpath...
...along the Westminster Bridge.
If I said someone was mad, what would that make you think of?
Probably insane.
Insane but if I said they were angry and that's how they were mad...
Mad.
Yeah that makes me mad.
That's a pure American usage.
"Mad" meaning angry goes all the way back to at least about 1400...
...according to the Oxford English dictionary.